is it love at this point no
it's not it's Duty it's commitment
it's
a faith that tells you you work it out
and stick it out I think if we both
really sat down we'd look at each other
and say really we've been separated for
several months what yeah Cody and I have
separated and I'm happy really happy
I don't know things just really became
sort of indifferent like I just didn't
care anymore when you became indifferent
did you still respect him yes yes
do you still respect him now
I I do but I'm I'm so mad about what's
happened with our kids
that it's very hard I'm losing respect
for him in that resp in that regard
Cody says he feels disrespected by you
well it's mutual I think it's a it's a
two-way street there
I think if he had truly been watching
out for me and my children he would have
figured out a way to make it work for
the whole family instead of having his
rules and hanging out with the wife
staying where his he was respected and
obeyed
Janelle's made it pretty clear to me
that she's
enjoying her life without me
hmm
she's like yeah you know I haven't
missed you much
do you want to work on it do you want to
try and fix it oh yeah absolutely
yeah hi I I don't I won't go to a place
where I'm not respected because love
doesn't matter to me respect matters to
me
so are you separated yes we are
separated
pretty stupid for people who love each
other huh Kinda Yeah
can't you fix it can she fix it do you
want to fix it
do you still need more room and time to
process I want to fix it yes yeah but
that that's a whole new negotiation
we're in a new place Christine's left
Janelle likes her
that one's just like why couldn't you
have been Good Sister Wives when you
were Sister Wives that's such a mess
[Music]